the summit between the leaders of North
and South Korea ended on Sunday that's
pretty compelling to watch that head
down a lot of people thought we'd never
see this happen right and one of the
most striking images was this shot of
North Korea's Kim jong-un arriving at
the summit with bodyguards running
alongside his limousine and if you saw
this this was absolutely absolutely blew
my mind when they showed up yeah
everyone was just blown away by that now
that seems like a lot of security I know
but if you're in the public eye trust me
you cannot be too careful in fact true
story Warner Brothers gave me my own
security detail don't giggle it's
necessary I am an iconic figure in
America Billy let's show the footage of
me coming back from lunch today at the
commissary okay that's me
then I realized I forgot I forgot to get
ketchup packets at the commissary so I'm
headed back and then a fan tried to get
a selfie but we took care of this is the
way
you started delusion I know toss me your
axillary hey we had to get that in one
take ever the director was like should
do it again I'm like I don't think we
should do it again
Gertrude can't handle it
[Music]
you